russian president vladimir putin says
this morning that his country is now
using the world's
first coronavirus vaccine putin says his
daughter has received it and is doing
well
authorities say russian medical workers
teachers and
others in high-risk groups will get the
vaccine first
our dr david agus is with us david what
do we know about this
vaccine and how much testing has it
actually been given so far
well anthony on june 18th they started
with about 38 volunteers at the current
administration that was
it was approved in russia and so we know
in those 38 individuals that there was
an immune response the state reported
not scientific journals the state
reported
but we don't know whether it actually
protects and we don't know what will
happen when large numbers of people are
inoculated
it's akin to 1957 and a sputnik moment
big proclamation
but i'm not sure all the data are there
yet so
does this change how the u.s and other
countries might approach vaccine
development do you think david
i certainly hope it doesn't change what
any country does in terms of vaccine
development most countries
are doing phase three studies that is
looking does this
vaccine actually protect and reduce the
symptoms
of cova 19 by at least 50 percent
not knowing it works you know it's very
hard to go forward but they are starting
to manufacture realize
that they've just announced approval
they have not manufactured for the 150
million people
in russia it will take them many many
months to manufacture enough doses it's
a two-part shot
so they need 300 million doses for the
country
it's going to take a long time but you
think the testing so far for the russian
virus vaccine rather
is inadequate right now it's almost a
political statement right that there is
no test that shows that this protects
anybody from covet 19.
all right david agus thank you very much